peu
[Musique]
et
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonsoir nous ne sommes pas ce soir dans
notre studio habituel de larry
cognacq-jay nous sommes installés là
l'endroit même où vont converger tout à
l'heure tous vos appels nous sommes en
effet installé au centre alès vp et si
nous avons changé notre dispositif
habituel c'est pour essayer d'établir
avec vous est notre invité unique ce
soir alexandre soljenitsyne un contact
plus sensible un contact plus concret
alexandre sont destinés donc ici avec
nous puisqu'il zac il a accepté de
répondre à vos questions je ne crois pas
qu'il soit utile de vous le présenter
disons simplement que c'est un écrivain
soviétique
exilée de son pays depuis deux ans
depuis 1974
c'est l'auteur d'un certain nombre de
romans de livres qui ont connu presque
tous un grand succès pour n'en citer que
quelques-uns mentionnons le premier
cercle le pavillon des cancéreux une
journée d'ivan denissovitch et puis les
trois tomes maintenant de l'archipel du
goulag dans lesquels alexandre
soljenitsyne dénonce la répression la
répression terrible qui s'opère dans les
prisons et dans les camps de
concentration soviétique à l'égard des
opposants du régime
il faut dire d'ailleurs que alexandre
soljenitsyne connaît parfaitement ses
camps et ses prisons soviétique
puisqu'il y a passé huit ans de sa vie
depuis qu'il a été exilé du rss depuis
deux ans maintenant
alexandre soljenitsyne a beaucoup voyagé
il est allé en france il est allé aux
états unis est allé au canada il était
né en angleterre est partout il a
dénoncé ce qui se passe en urss et
surtout il a mis en garde les
occidentaux contre ce qu'ils considèrent
être pour eux un très grand danger
contre la détente entre les deux blocs
la détente entre l'est et l'ouest mais
de cela nous parlerons tout à l'heure
nous parlons d'ailleurs de bien d'autres
choses puisque je voulais dit il ya un
instant
alexandre soljenitsyne a accepté ce soir
d'être votre interlocuteur privilégié
d'être face à face avec vous-même et de
répondre à toutes les questions que vous
voudrez bien
lui poser tout à l'heure quels que
soient ces questions même si elles lui
sont défavorables
alors comment on va fonctionner notre
système est bien dans un instant vous
allez découvrir l'autre partie des vp
vous allez découvrir avant jamot vous
allez découvrir guide arbois gilles
berkane qui tout au long de cette soirée
vont recevoir vos questions vont
l'étrier vont les sélectionnés grâce à
l'aide bien entendu de toutes les
standardistes
dsb voyant ce moment nos camarades
armand jammot guide arbois gilbert
cannes
je leur demande d'ailleurs de vous
donner davantage de précisions sur le
dispositif est bien à la jérôme le
dispositif est en place les personnes
qui doivent y travailler vont arriver
dans quelques minutes dès le début du
film
et puis les fiches vont arriver il y a
le standard arrivent les appels eu ces
appels des téléspectateurs sont
répercutés vers des opérateurs et des
opératrices qui sous la dictée des
téléspectateurs prennent la question de
chacun
cette question était inscrite sur une
fiche et puis les 6 ch vous le verrez à
la fin du film vont arriver sur son
bureau et je crois que nous serons pas
trop de trois avec armand jammot et
gilbert cannes pour les dépouiller et
poser le maximum de questions qui
intéresseront l'ensemble des
téléspectateurs et nous sommes prêts
nous bien après je dois dire alain que
les téléspectateurs doivent attendre que
comme d'habitude comme chaque semaine le
panneau pendant le film vers 21h10 passe
pour l'art indiqué qu'à partir de ce
moment là ils pourront nous appeler et
ils auront plus de 2h15 pour nous
appeler bon c'est à dire à peu près dans
une demi heure
alors avant d'entendre notre invité
unique ce soir alexandre s'était dit il
répondra aux premières questions qui
parviendront svp je vous propose de
regarder ensemble un film un film qui
s'intitule une
journée d'ivan denissovitch c'est un
film qui est tirée justement d'un des
romans de notre invité de ce soir et qui
raconte une journée dans un camp de
travail
[Musique]
et bien je vous ai dit tout à l'heure en
commençant cette émission et là je
m'adresse à ceux qui auraient pris cette
émission pendant le film nous ne sommes
pas dans notre suivi habituel de la rue
cognacq-jay nous sommes installés dans
les locaux de ce bp là même où vos
appels téléphoniques vont converger tout
au long de la soirée ils sont déjà très
nombreux au standard
un standard qui se trouve à quelques
mètres de nous dans une autre pièce un
standard que vous allez voir dans un
instant un standard où se trouvent
réunies marcel jullian armand jammot dit
d'arbois gilbert kahn qui vont tout au
long de cette soirée
recevoir vos questions transmises par
les standardistes et qui vont les trier
les sélectionner et les poser à monsieur
soljenitsyne juge zinn est ici avec nous
je voudrais d'abord le remercier en
commençant cette émission d'avoir
accepté ce face à face avec vous c'est à
dire avec les téléspectateurs qui nous
regardent et en ce moment même par
millions et dire que il a regardé ce
film une journée d'ivan denissovitch
avec un certain nombre de remarques qui
l'a fait tout au long de du film mais
comme je sais qu'il y a de votre côté
c'est à dire du côté du standard du côté
d'armand jammu de marcel jullian le
guide arborait gilbert qu'à un certain
nombre de questions qui justement ont
trait au film et à la façon dont
l'oeuvre de alexandre soljenitsyne a été
respectée je vous propose deux peut-être
commencer par là et de nous donner
lecture des premières questions qui vous
sont en recul sur ce point précis et
bien d'abord aidé à revoir alain et
messieurs soljenitsyne je vous montre
les premières filles qui sont arrivés
depuis à peu près une heure
nous en avons vraiment partout et nous
sommes capables maintenant nous en
sommes persuadés de faire l'émission
pendant au moins dix heures tant la
curiosité des téléspectateurs est grande
en ce qui concerne laventure complète
d'alexandre soljenitsyne alexandre
soljenitsyne sur la personne duquel déjà
les téléspectateurs portent des
jugements
différents pour certains il est
on lui reproche d'être un agent de
propagande anti soviétique et
anticommuniste on lui reproche également
de tout faire pour que la détente
n'existe plus pour d'autres et ils sont
très nombreux il faut le dire
c'est à la fois un héros un martyr un
prophète il reçoit des témoignages
d'amitié de félicitations on lui dit
merci
et puis aussi et je le disais on le
prend pour un prophète parce qu'on lui
pose des questions sur la situation en
iran en amérique latine en afrique un
peu partout je dois dire aussi que healy
a effectivement des questions sur le
film on lui demande par exemple c'est un
document une documentaliste madame et de
chevilly larue qui lui demande si le
film satisfait l'auteur du livre s'il
considère qu'il est fidèle à son ouvrage
ce que vous voulez répondre que le
metteur en scène et les acteurs de ce
film ont abordé le film avec beaucoup
d'honnêteté et avec une grande
pénétration
ils n'ont pas éprouvé tout cela ils
n'ont pas vécu cela mais ont réussi à
pénétrer à deviner cette atmosphère
perçante et ont réussi à donner ce teint
peau de la vie dans les camps qui
remplit la vie d'un détenu pendant dix
ans parfois même pendant 25 ans
s'ils ne meurent pas avant comme cela
arrive le plus souvent
quelques petits reproches peuvent être
faites à l'exécution le plus souvent
c'est celle là où l'imagination
occidental ne peut absolument pas se
représenter
les détails de cette vie par exemple
pour notre oeil à nous pour mon oeil à
moi ou bien si mes amis soviétique
pouvait le voir les anciens mais qu
est-ce qui verront jamais ce film pour
notre oeil par exemple les les unes les
uniformes sont trop propre presque tous
ont beaucoup trop ample et mai mais en
fait ils étaient tous à limite à la
limite de la mort les joues et et caves
les forces
il n'avait plus de force du tout dans
les bars à qui fait si chaud que
multimania se trouve ici mains nues et
pieds nus c'est impossible
il aurait gelé mais ce sont des
remarques tout à fait secondaire mais
dans l'ensemble je dois dire que je suis
étonné comment l'auteur de ce film a pu
comprendre à ce point là et avec ça
s'hérite et sans aucun but extérieur
essayer de rendre au spectateur
occidental
nos souffrances vous avez passé combien
de temps dans un camp comme celui ci
dans ce camp spécial type bagnard j'ai
passé trois ans et qui aujourd'hui
encore en 1976 des cons comme celui-là
ça joue précisément je suis en train
j'écris prête dans le troisième temps de
l'archipel qui vient de paraître dans la
septième partie staline et plus mais
dans cette étonnante histoire
à tel point notre système est fermé par
lui-même que le choc avait pleuré
sincèrement sur vivendi nicevic et la
même année
il avait donné sa signature à 4 régime
pénitentiaire qui existent jusqu'à
maintenant toutes les deux les plus
sévères dépasse même le régime que nous
voulons des voix en d'autres termes
malheureusement ce film ne parle pas du
passé
ce film parle également du présent et là
il faut faire un homard suivante dans le
troisième tome de l'archipel j'écris
également les temps passe il est plus
commode aujourd'hui tous ceux qui
protestent tous et tous ceux qui ne
correspondent pas en province au but
officiel
il est préférable de les coffrets non
pour des lois non pour des lois
politiques mais pour des lois
criminelles et c'est ainsi qu'il ya des
camps d'après andré savard en fils y
aurait un million et demi de détenus
actuellement je ne conteste pas ce
chiffre mais toute notre statistiques et
secrète
il ya des camps énorme et avec un régime
comme nous venons de voir une autre
question
c'est armand jammot qui l'appauvrît bien
avant de poser une question la question
d'un téléspectateur à monsieur c'est une
question à laquelle je dois
personnellement répondre sous le
contrôle du président julien ya une
question que nous retrouvons fréquemment
dans les fiches et ils nous demandent
pour quelle raison nous avons
diffusé ce débat se soit reprogrammé ce
débat ce soir entre les deux tours des
élections cantonales
alors on ira informations nous n'avons
pas véritablement choisi cette date
c'est monsieur seul génie in women qu'il
l'a choisi nous avons négocié avec lui
depuis très longtemps et monsieur jean
n'avait de dates disponibles que
celle-ci deuxième considération
je ne vois pas en quoi évoquer la
situation dans les camps soviétiques un
quelconque rapportant avec la vie
politique en france
cela dit je voudrais poser la question
d'un téléspectateur c'est aussi une
question du matériel personnellement
pourquoi monsieur soljenitsyne attendait
pour toi monsieur johnny jean est il
allé dans un camp attendu s'il vous
plaît allez on commence et de trois mois
ce genre de voyage il faut les concertée
bien à l avance et que vous aviez des
élections cantonales
moi je ne les ai appris qu aujourd'hui
la suivante il ya un rapport ya un
rapport dans l'échelle des choses et
cette question mais donne quelques peu
est il possible qu'en ayant vu ce film
on puisse poser ce genre de questions
armand jammot bon maintenant venons dans
la gestion que je voulais poser au nom
de des téléspectateurs qui l'ont poussé
pourquoi monsieur soljenitsyne at il été
interné si longtemps dans les camps at
il fait l'objet d'un poids c'est
régulier at il bénéficié de l'assistance
d'un avocat
je dois dire que précisément bateau
comme dans ce torrent de plusieurs
millions d'hommes
je ne considère pas que je suis une
victime tout à fait innocente
d'après l'échelle de cette époque là en
réalité au moment de mon arrestation je
suis arrivé à avoir une opinion tout à
fait destructrice de staline et même
avec mon ami qui a partagé mon sort nous
avons signé un document en commun sur la
nécessité de modifier l'appareil
gouvernemental se vident sic je ne me
sens bien je ne suis jamais sentie
véritablement arrêté comme un innocent
mais quand j'étais dans ce torrent j'ai
été frappée que le torrent lui était
constituée d'innocents que les gens
avaient envoyé vraiment pour rien
vraiment pour absolument rien
précisément comme ivan 18 chf
le héros de ce film est ce que vous avez
est ce que vous avez pour reprendre la
deuxième partie la troisième partie est
ce que vous avez été jugée régulièrement
et est ce que vous aviez un avocat pour
vous défendre
il n'y a eu aucun tribunal aucun
jugement
c'était simplement la commission
spéciale c'est une troïka de personnes
ferney secrète
il n'y a aucun jugement il n'y a aucun
avocat
on vous donne simplement un papier vous
devez signer que vous avez écopé de huit
ans
nos questions berkane oui une question
qui revient à plusieurs reprises dans
les appels que nous avons eu ce soir
dans ces camps de travail que connaît
bien seul génie de sin est ce qu'il y
avait ce qu'il y avait des cours
d'endoctrinement politique
votre show là encore un privilège des
camps staliniens par rapport à ceux
d'aujourd'hui
non non il n'y avait aucun travail
politique précisément dans ces camps
spéciaux qui ont été montrés dans ce
film il n'y avait aucune radio qui nous
matraquent set j'ai véritablement notre
bonheur dans certains lots cas de ce
type nous avions des chaînes les
prisonniers portée des chaînes mais
jamais de travail politique avec les
prisonniers
la difficulté des décors actuelle c'est
que actuellement on oblige les détenus à
écouter une propagande insupportable et
l'a prouvé
sans quoi on les envoie dans les caches
ont été libérés
[Musique]
j'ai été libéré
quand j'ai purgés quand j'ai purgé ma
peine et sans aucun jugement sans aucune
sentence uniquement par une signature
donné au bout de papier en m'a donné la
rélégation perpétuel à perpétuité match
on s'est dit si tu allais qu'on n'avait
pas été dit sur cette animation était
pas mort je suis resté encore trois ans
dans les camps sans coach rester encore
plus longtemps
une autre question armand j'aime
beaucoup de téléspectateurs
vous l'aurez savoir qu'elles sont d'une
façon générale les motifs pour lesquels
des personnes comme monsieur socgen et
jean se trouve internés dans les camps
en union soviétique
quels sont les différents motifs de c2c
internement je voudrais bien distinguer
le temps ou quand j'étais dans les camps
et le temps actuel à mon époque en 45 46
quand j'ai été dans les camps ceux qui
ont été nos frais pour délit d'opinion
nous n'étions pas très nombreux shows il
y avait un livre un immense torrent de
tout ce qu'ils avaient il s'était trouvé
en europe
d'après les constatations la commission
de rêve de rapatriation aussitôt après
la guerre les autorités soviétiques ont
réussi à récupérer d'europe occidentale
plus de cinq millions de personnes comme
nous l'apprenons aujourd'hui dans les
documents américains et anglais 1
million plus d'un million et demi ont
été rapatriés de force ni par traîtrise
une très grosse propagande a été
développé en europe selon laquelle le
système avait changé qu'il n'y avait
plus d'incarcérations que les kolkhozes
ont été 10
que l'église est désormais libre que la
russie avait été reconstituée non pas
lurs du point de vue de l'esprit et
plusieurs millions ont cru et comme des
papillons se sont portés vers le feu
numéro de tasmanie bâton chili et non à
mon époque dans ces torrents il y avait
énormément de rapatriement je ne vais
pas retenir l'attention du
téléspectateur trop longtemps tous et
aux rentes été décrit par mois dans
l'archipel tome 1 il y avait des
torrents depuis 1917 et jusqu'à
maintenant mais il était maudit fêtons
aujourd'hui vrai que je voudrais
expliquer pour ça soit bien conscient de
prisonniers politiques semblent s'ils
n'ont pas tellement dans certains
évidemment on les cache dans les prisons
psychiatrique mais des gens qui sont
chaque au monde qui protestent contre
les autorités qui dénonce sur place on
l'est on les justes pour droit commun et
les incarcère non comme droit commun
mais recherche a brisé leur volonté est
ce que est ce que le le public russe
l'homme de la rue soviétique connaît
l'existence de ces camps
l'existence de l'archipel on le connaît
ce cas je m'aligne parce que dans toute
localité il ya quelqu'un qui se trouve
incarcéré
mais bien entendu dans les provinces de
cuillé et et moscou on a une
représentation différente de la chose
moscou en général ne ressemble en rien
tout le reste l'union soviétique je
serai dans des meilleures conditions
d'information et même en général de
choléra ce matériel la vigilance est la
plus développée
ithaque alors à ce qui vient qu'elle
soit développée un peu partout où les un
monstre tard il se présente évidemment
de façon plus générale on connaît un
certain nombre de noms on peut
généraliser en province on ne connaît
que des cases isolé reçoit des lettres
des corps les gens savent les leur
connaît selon l'un des leurs mais
n'arrivent pas généraliser mais tout le
monde sait qu'il ya des régimes aussi
sévère dans les camps des rendez-vous
bien passé les rendez vous les visites
sont refusés on envoie des colis sauf
que à quel point il est plus grand et
puis ils arrivent ils arrivent nous en
est un exemple n'est fini de purger sa
peine et qu'on en sorte
à ce moment on raconte en effet une
autre question
oui d'abord je voudrais dire alain que
nous sommes absolument submergés sous
les fiches que anne marie la mort y a
beaucoup de mal à trier celle qui nous
arrive et qu'il faut absolument que les
téléspectateurs pendant quelques minutes
cesse de nous appeler pour que nous
puissions d'abord prendre toutes les
communications qui sont en attente
d'avoir une vue du standard pour cent
comptent jouer non c'est vraiment ici
l'affolement mais nous nous en tirons
bien gilbert cannes où il ya une
question qui fait suite d'ailleurs à la
question que vous venez de poser alain
jérôme à savoir beaucoup de
téléspectateurs se demande comment les
prisonniers de ces camps arrive à
survivre et ceux qui en sortiront
s'étonne malgré tout je sais bien que
l'urss est grande mais on s'étonne que
d'autres en dehors de soljenitsyne n'ai
pas pu parler et raconter ce qui se
passait dans ces camps et puis il ya une
autre une autre question qui
poser également qui est de savoir s'il
existe des camps pour les femmes et pour
les enfants et si ces camps sont très
différent de ce qu'a montré seul génie
sin dans la mesure où il ya plusieurs
qui se fait peut-être les noter que
l'archipel existe en fait grâce des
renseignements ont pénétré en occident
plusieurs arias mon arrivée ici celui
constaté qu'il a eu plus de marquer dix
ont été publiés sur l'archipel depuis la
fin des années vingt noms d'individus
dire la même chose étrange ni chrétien
l'occident ne voulait pas entendre ces
témoignages et ne voulaient pas leur
prêter foi - archi piroi rouge red bull
initiatique ni mon archipel était déjà
dans la 4e dizaine des livres il a fallu
plusieurs décennies pour qu'enfin cette
voix soit entendue et 6 des témoins sur
les témoins d'occident ont prétendu que
c'était mon songe de grands de grands
penseurs occidentaux ont affirmé qu'il
n'y avait pas de femmes ils endurent ce
alors que six millions de paysans sont
morts en ukraine et dans le couvent il y
a eu des procès des hommes publics ou
des hommes deux parties occidentaux
jurés sur la foi de serre du serment
qu'il n'y avait pas de camp de
concentration murs des voies sont
toujours fait entendre dans le confort
on ne veut pas entendre la vérité parce
que si on apprend tout cet horrible
vérité il faut faire quelque chose il
faut tendre la main pour rien
or on n'en n'a guère envie cette
explication psychologique me paraît être
la plus importante
l'autre question sur les différents
champs je n'aurais pas répercutée
ce que j'ai dit dans l'archipel
je pense que les téléspectateurs sont
également des lecteurs qui peuvent lire
même comment les les camps étaient
organisés les camps spéciaux pour favori
quand pour moufles et pour adolescents
en fait j'ai là j'ai sous les yeux le
tome 3 de l'archipel du goulag et vous
lancez une sorte d'appel dans la fin du
livre dans la postface vous dites ce
livre je n'aurais pas dû l'écrire seuls
les différents chapitres a dû être
réparti entre les personnes compétentes
et ensuite nous serions réunis en
conseil de rédaction pour corriger le
tout en les aidant mutuellement et vous
a ajouté je veux aussi lancé un appel
dès que le temps sera venu
dès que vous en aurez la possibilité
vous mes amis qui est revenu de
l'archipel qui le connaissaient bien
rassembler vous et écrivez un
commentaire pour le joindre à ce que
j'ai écrit là où il le faut corriger là
où il le faut compléter autrement dit
c'est un set un témoignage qui vous est
propre pour une grande partie
mais c'est aussi le fruit de récits dont
nous parlions tout à l'heure c'est à
dire que vous avez vous aussi rencontrer
d'autres gens qui ont été emprisonnés et
vous les à vous avait consigné leurs
récits dans ce livre j'étais dans des
dans une circonstance particulière
grosse pression à la publication du
livre yvan denissovitch ce livre
l'archipel où la crise commençait à
vendre avant que yves un discours public
mais ensuite j'ai compris que je ne
pourrais jamais mené a mis à la tâche
l'essence de man et moi tout ce que j'ai
trouvé ce conte est prouvé mes amis
s'étaient pas suffisants pour construire
un grand lit ta van driessche a été
publiée il ya une courte période
j'ai été très heureux très bien admis en
russie soviétique
hier cette technique à cette époque la
suisse est comme un torrent de lettres
de tous les coins de la russie
les anciens d'hec me raconter dans leur
lettre voulait me rencontrer pour leur
santé ars moralement et pendant un court
temps avant ma disgrâce
j'ai réussi à sectionner tous ces
anciens cercles et à réunir un très
grand matériel bastille sera dans
documentation 6 mai c'est là donc j'ai
écrit mon livre mais ma peau strassées
toujours valable tout le matériel est
sous tension et si immense que même de
nombreux volumes ne serait pas suffisant
pour l'embrasser
ce livre ne peut être plus grand s'il
avait plus de trois volumes l'écouteur
ne pourrait en venir à bout
mais j'espère que viendront en
expliquant dans la patrie sans obstacle
les témoins france se réunir réunir des
documents et constituer une histoire de
plusieurs volumes
peut-être pas pour l'électeur le
polissoir pour ceux qui doivent
connaître d'autres questions oui c'est
armand jammot une question de
vocabulaire tue et posé par beaucoup de
téléspectateurs le sens exact de
l'archipel du goulag
est-ce que ça désigne un quand est-ce
que ça désigne un ensemble de quand
est-ce que ça désigne une partie du
territoire soviétique à l'intérieur
duquel des gens sont prisonniers des
camps ces essais mais sur toute
l'étendue de l'union soviétique est
formé de petits îlots et parfois de
grands tous ensemble on peut pas se
représenter
ça votre vin on ne peut pas trouver
d'autres messages forts ils sont pas
déclarés demain boys ils sont séparés
comme un os par un autre missile au dans
l'eure mais si tu perds composent
l'habituel qu'il ya une instruction à la
radio ce gâchis cesser d'utiliser le mot
archipel même dans une émission
géographie
et ce mot kit unir s'est reconnue est
maintenant interdit que maintenant quand
il faut parler d'un archipel ont dit un
groupe d'îles en russie oui votre chose
oui c'est l' aventure personnelle aussi
d'alexandre soljenitsyne qui intéresse
les téléspectateurs lui demande quels
sont les plus durs moments qu'il a vécu
pendant sa détention
les fiascos valérie blachère iode de ma
réclusion c'est le débat et les routes
c'est le choc c'est le passage dans une
existence une existence qu'on pense ne
pas pouvoir supporter et ensuite il y a
eu vent des moments particuliers d année
particulière ça ça dépend de chacun moi
jamais je n'aurais survécu dans ces
conditions je n'aurais jamais survécu
parce que je n'avais pas de spécialités
manuel au début j'ai survécu chose que
j'ai été pris pour quatre ans dans un
institut d'études et de recherches pour
des tenues alors la période la plus
difficile a été la première année et
ensuite les trois dernières celles qui
ont été montrés dans le film mais déjà
il y avait une certaine lueur il ne
restait plus que trois en récession si
riche et j'ai appris à être le métier de
maçon est ce que j'ai donné à cette
profession les presser cette profession
et d'un dîner chez les pressions poser
les débris comme on l'a fait ivan illich
m'a reproché d'avoir montré que des
esclaves sont entraînés sont enflammés
par leur travail
c'est étonnant mais c'est comme ça mais
moi aussi dans ces conditions j'ai été
entraîné à ce travail j'ai entraîné pour
pour en faire davantage et pour la ferme
ou à certains moments bien entendu ils
vendent des niches qui n'a pas d'autre
intérêt que le travail s'il n'est pas
entraînés par ce travail il mourrait
syrie sur le monde
cet entraînement par un travail
d'esclave c'est sa façon
maintenir son l'intégrité de son être
cette scène par la suite a permis à rhj
of any d'autoriser cette heure ils ont
cru que de cette façon là je glorifier
le travail socialiste
geep et bien à l'âge nous avons pris la
décision nous tous ensemble de ne plus
poser de questions sur le goulag parce
que nous pourrions aller jusqu'à minuit
il y à d'autres chapitres de la
curiosité des téléspectateurs et marcel
jullian à puiser dans ce paquet des
fiches qui l'intéressent personnellement
oui non il ya deux deux questions qui
reviennent souvent la première venant
surtout d'étudiants fait état de
l'étouffement de la pensée en urss et
pose la question est ce que les russes
connaissent l'existence de ces camps et
notamment comment réagissent les jeunes
la seconde question on retrouve à
plusieurs reprises et qui émanent là
d'un agent technique est la suivante
quel est selon vous le dessin du
gouvernement soviétique en libérant
soljenitsyne au procès les questions
sont différentes et je vais donc
répondre séparément at on dit que notre
jeunesse ne puisse connaître ceux qui la
menacent
bien sûr qu'elle connaît il faut bien
comprendre que nous avons tout un
spectre influence sur la jeunesse l'a
forcé à renoncer à la liberté de pensée
et adopter la façon de penser officiels
se sont pas seulement les plus dangereux
ce sont les plus dangereux que l'on met
dans les prisons pic dans les prisons
prêt à foncer dans les camps mais pour
agir sur des dizaines et des centaines
de milliers de jeunes il ya d'autres
moyens d'influencé moins décisif mais
ils sont cependant offert en slide
si un homme serge quilly à une prison
psychiatrique
kylie à un camp il n'est pas nécessaire
que chacun les pistes passe par lui il
est passible de priver un homme de son
travail donc en occident je ne pouvais
pas le priver de son travail par une
décision gouvernementale
parce que s'ils ont pris le travail
j'irai dans un autre endroit travail oui
mais si chez nous on au prix du travail
on n'en trouve nulle part on va on peut
crever de faim mais on ne trouvera
jamais de travailler parce que la
liaison téléphonique au père marchés ont
peu cynique nahla boîtier à souge digne
nombreux par des condamnations créer des
difficultés au travail donner des
emplois subalternes refusé le domicile
le soin du domicile payer moins cher et
ces derniers temps toutes ces dernières
années précisément l'influencé sur les
étudiants s'est renforcé dans les
instituts dans les écoles supérieures
c'est une chose terrible c'est pire que
toute propagande politique
il ya tant de leur politique en dehors
des heures de cours qui sont tellement
augmenté et il faut passer des examens
spéciaux pour la maturité politique
d'enseignement supérieur est
actuellement empoisonné que de plus en
plus de plus en plus les jeunes refusent
l'enseignement supérieur pour éviter de
passer aux danseurs hachoir il préfère
le travail manuel
plutôt que d'éviter de rabâcher des
choses auxquelles ils ne croient plus du
tout plastique et réponse à la première
question je voudrais qu'on me précise la
seconde oui alors la seconde question et
la question est posée de façon pas très
adéquat le gouvernement soviétique en
défense de zone a dessiné avez la
possibilité avait le choix avait la
possibilité de choisir entre deux
solutions montre plusieurs solutions
dans mon cas présent c'est bien dit
voilà ce qui s'est passé
l'opinion publique occidentale a montré
une fermeté en colère à mon sujet et à
propos d'andré sakharov que nous étions
tous les deux faire sécurité en autant
de 1973 longtemps depuis de nombreuses
années le gouvernement n'avait rien
entendu de tel geste que l'occident
toutes les couches sociales
indépendamment de leur appartenance au
parti avec une telle insistance et avec
des conclusions qui allait si bien
exprimé leur indignation
avec tant d'insistance que le 20 janvier
tic a eu peur simplement il faut le
comprendre akhdar movie du camp nous
voyons sa victoire avait prévu que
l'union soviétique vol de victoire en
victoire qui ont freiné chez ce que nous
voyons pas nier la marche triomphale à
travers notre planète sa vie monastique
rhône michel sport résiste à travers
toutes les tâches contemporaine à
l'exclusion à samedi le la lecture on
peut croire qu'ils sont tout puissants
mais en fait ils ne sont tout puissants
que quand ils ne rencontrent pas de
résistance
ce n'est pas par une décision libre du
mordant soviétique qui m'envoyait en en
occident mais ils ont ces contrées à le
faire on peut parler de but que comme
d'un calcul or la chaux-de-fonds leurs
calculs
tu ne pourrais pas contenir cette
indignation s'ils me maintenait en
prison ou en relégation qui est beaucoup
plus plus simple et plus facile de
m'exiler oui mais en vous laissant
partir rien vous exigeants ils savaient
que très probablement ou férié ce que
vous faites ici ce soir avec nous ce que
vous avez fait aux états unis où ce que
vous avez fait en angleterre c'est à
dire que vous dénoncez un certain nombre
de choses qui se passent chez eux
vous savez dénoncé plus que je les fais
dans l'archipel ce n'est pas possible
à cette époque on entend de 73 plus
exactement en automne ils ont réussi à
intercepter l'archipel j'ai donné
l'ordre public en occident haut débit de
74 ils ont vu je suis entre leurs noms
mais ça n'a pas arrêté l'archipel ils
ont essayé d'entrer en pourparlers avec
moi et m'ont proposé de ne pas publier
l'archipel pourquoi il voulait rien il
me proposait de publier les régions des
cancers et moi j'ai pris la décision de
publier l'archipel alors voilà ce qu'ils
pensaient il pensait qu'il m'avait il
pensait qu'il avait étranglé mais
l'archipel aurait paru tout entier et
leur le volume iii lui aurait paru
également qu' une plus grande
accusations un plus grand livre
quelles que soient mes interventions
devant les télévisions il n'y a pas de
plus grande accusations au monde
est ce que est ce que vous avez été
l'objet de menaces
vous semblez souvent crâne pour votre
sécurité
là il faudrait distinguer il faudrait
trouver un nom précis crainte
appréhension suppose la peur moi je suis
paré à la mort depuis très longtemps
les premières émeutes qui ont eu lieu
dans les camps et vanilla nous étions
tous prêts à affronter la mort et la
syrie il me restait plus qu'un an à
cirer nous mais nous avions tels nausées
que nous tous nous disions tuez-nous à
partir de ce moment là c'est passé n'y a
pas un seul jour par cette année une
autre attitude
chaque année qu'il est un parti de plus
je remercie dieu d'avoir fait que j'ai
d'avoir pu faire un travail je ne crains
pas pour ma vie a dit bayan c'est à dire
je n'ai pas craint là j'ai publié
l'archipel en occident tout en me trouve
en russie soviétique et ma vie se
trouvait entre leurs mains mais
simplement raisonnablement je sais je
reçois parfois des informations d'union
soviétique et je sais quelles décisions
sont prises là bas il avait fait le
calcul a abandonné hasard près de nous
il y en occident peut-être comme
l'écrivain arcis je ne serai plus qu'on
ne porterait plus d'intérêt envers mon
oeuvre jeudi en vue que ce n'est pas
tout à fait comme ça mais que les livres
continuent à apparaître
je pense que ils ont pris la décision ce
genre de décision mais je répète depuis
cinquante deux depuis ce temps que
j'évoquais et s'est passé déjà 25 ans +
moi je vis mes amis vif
nous sommes tous ses envies si nous
avions peur de la mort l'europe est très
justifiée et ne rompt pas été sauvée oui
vous n'avez pas répondu tout à fait à ma
question est ce que vous êtes l'objet de
menaces
bien entendu tant en pistant des lettres
arrivent au journal j'en avais reçu
assez grand nombre soviétique
ici à gamenson reçoit il ya également
les attaques par téléphone des menaces
par téléphone
mais les menaces évidemment collet mais
il s'agit de décisions sérieuses prises
notre question oui
gilbert can we voudrais rappeler et
certains aux téléspectateurs l'ont
rappelé d'ailleurs que monsieur
soljenitsyne a été libéré le jour même
de la mort de staline et certains
d'entre eux disent que khrouchtchev a
donné personnellement son feu vert pour
l'édition de son livre du fil du livre
dont nous avons vu le film ce soir une
journée d'ivan denissovitch et on
demande également monsieur soljenitsyne
si khrouchtchev ne s'est pas servi de ce
livre pour en urss pratiquer ces
opérations de déstabilisation
à ce moment là ma libération le jour de
la mort de staline c'est une pure
coïncidence purement symbolique vraiment
on ne rêve pas imaginer c'est pas une
véritable libération mais un passage en
relégation
il ya eu coïncidence s'il est bien exact
que staline est mort le 5 mars mais
personne ne sait exactement le jour de
sa mort la seconde question concernant
christophe canioni bien entendu julie
poinot il réchauffe n'a pas compris ils
ont 18 nouvelles boues il mener son
combat politique à cette époque là
à cette époque là je ne comprenais pas
moi même il fallait qu'ils jettent un
atout dans la lutte avec la chine
casa liste et la pensée voilà un récit
mais si tu parles de souffrance mais en
même temps il ya un certain enthousiasme
pour le travail imprimons le
humour pagnard chauffe ne pouvez pas
comprendre
rappelé par dés qu'une goutte de vérité
vichyste pas par une matière qui se
trouvent dans l'antimatière d'azun il
explose ce taux était de 7 9 février en
union soviétique avec l'approbation du
parti ne peut être ce que ne pas être
entendue dans le monde entier
trente livres avant moi n'ont pas reçu
d'audience mais là le parti lui-même à
küblis lives ai dit ça a été ainsi les
thomistes occidentaux se sont trouvés
dans l'impasse et tous les défenseurs
libéraux d'un tel régime il ne
comprenait pas vraiment ce qu'ils au
comité central est certain qu'on prenait
mary chauffe lui avait usé de son
autorité en dépit de la majorité du
comité central il ne comprenait pas
toutes les conséquences
ils ne peuvent pas comprendre en général
l'importance de l'art est il de la
parole si pour récompense là ils ne
seraient pas ce qu'ils sont c'est
au-dessus de hippies
nous étions en train de nous dire que le
temps passé à une vitesse effrayante
beaucoup de questions qu'elle pose et on
a énormément notamment celle ci que
pensez vous monsieur soljenitsyne de la
situation des juifs soviétiques
est ce que le système communiste ni
béninois nietzsche est il n'a pas porté
bonheur aux 8e et même d'évolution
journal sauf n'y a qu'en fin de compte
ça au dessus des nationalités de l'union
soviétique nationale n'a commencé qu'à
dont les chuetas par le peuple russe qui
est la base même de la nation d'origine
estime qu avec d autres les autres
nations et peuples à la périphérie et
d'autres qui sont essaimé à travers
l'espace comme l'institut ski luge uma
différentes au galet le régime
communiste a appuyé différentes pcsi
tout le choc porté sur les risques et
les peuples mineurs ont plutôt été ils
sont tenus aux privilégiés mais au bout
d'un certain nombre de décennies la
machine à tourner dans un sens un peu
inverse d'aller défier l'autorité
centrale au contraire ensuite apporté
son coup sûr si bien les peuples et au
fuel et c'est ainsi que les juifs ont
support chiffrer la variation de cette
coupe est actuellement plus du double il
est difficile d'imaginer une
légitimation raisonnable pourquoi
empêcher les juifs de sortir du pays
ces juifs qui veulent sortir leur choix
ce qu'ils valent une culture autonome
pourquoi ne pas leur donner à ceux qui
restent cette culture j'avais systema
mais le système est si cruel spectre
massabeau elle ne peut cesser d'être ce
qu'elle est elles ne servent en général
ils et elles ne peut adopter des
solutions raisonnables ou agir par
sympathie c'est ainsi que les juifs sont
privés pour le croisement juste leurs
possibilités de développement culturel
de même de nombreuses nations sont
également privés de leur centre culture
stade à eau tandis que le dow le chef le
russe a souffert le plus long distance
au point de vue et quantitatifs
quantitativement et qualitativement guy
oui marcel julien a sélectionné trois
fiches
oui la première c'est que c'est la seule
de ce genre il faut la cité est un
récital anticommuniste que nous
orchestrons non c'est une fille sur plus
de 7000 là pour répondre à ça ya deux
questions à peu près semblables tout de
même comment expliquer le degré de
développement scientifique alors que la
politique sociale reste siens juste
comment pouvez vous expliquer que ce
régime de terreur permettent l'éclosion
de savants et d'ingénieurs d'artistes et
de grands écrivains des performances
sportives et des expériences positives
dans de nombreux domaines
en d'autres termes comment faire
cohabiter le goulag et les réalisations
soviétique
[Musique]
je rédige tandis qu'il y a pourquoi il
ya contradiction ce schisme ovale goulag
l'existence du village contredit par les
tiques jovovich ou contredit les
sentiments humains touchants creux dit
lannoy breaker mais ils ne compteront
dit nullement une industrie gigantesque
des domaines différents poissons des
questions qu'après quatre mois ce sont
des questions qui ne sont pas en rapport
avec ce qui concerne le niveau technique
de haut et scientifique
voilà qu'elle dise on peut établir l
inverse grâce au travail progresse
d'esclaves de l'archipel dans l'archi et
qu'il y avait des dizaines de milliers
d'intellectuels travaillé dans le passé
avant tout dans des conditions les
sakalava styliste yves parenteau qui
travaillent dans des conditions où l'on
n'allait pas se désunir et alors il y
avait une filature policière constante
séparer de l'occident vire 4 quand ces
conditions rien
lochte fini
le plus haut niveau atteint est ironique
aux vestiges mis au monde ne pouvait
atteindre ce niveau plus haut niveau et
c'est voilà pour savoir ça use tac jade
9 millions de l'union soviétique
maintenant sont avidement cherche midi
nous apprendre zanetti n'est pas
l'occident et en particulier de la soie
ballon et l'ebit de la réussite des
reliques de l'occident et jeux pour sa
défense
et pour la suite a vite et décide dans
l'industrie pourquoi l'union ainsi que
besoin de commerces précision parce que
j'ai ce niveau n'existe pas parce que
donc la liaison est tout à fait inverse
la relation est à fait inverse niveau le
style trop d'à comme les arts à vannes
et à tous les paliers world nestier town
on assiste à une question parce que les
talents sont enferrés un niveau
véritablement quand un niveau que notre
pays aurait certainement atteint s'il
n'y avait pas eu la révolution
s'il n'y avait pas eu toutes les
catastrophes et la terreur
ce niveau ce niveau que nous aurions pu
atteindre
nous ne l'avons pas et notre
intelligentsia technique et scientifique
a été persécuté dessinée annihiler qu'on
était obligé de former de nouveaux cas
dans suite une question tu peu brutal
mais précise vous n'êtes plus vous
n'êtes plus vous n'avez jamais été
communiste communiste en communion en
tant que membres des partis n'ont jamais
non mais il fut un temps il fut un temps
dans la jeunesse dans les années trente
cadavres ont accueilli quand quand le
torrent de propagande politique quand je
lisais lénine marx engels à l'institut
je croyais découvrir devait de grandes
vérités et même à cette époque nous
avions une reconnaissance nous étions
reconnaissant mars qu'elle
toute la philosophie antérieures 25 ans
de de penser il fallait pu les lire
grâce à marx il est vrai qu'il est assez
difficile de mars mais mais mais il ya
également des manuels qui permette qui
facilite le travail c'est un terrible
poison
quand on vous dit que la vérité trouvé
que la vérité sur les paumes de la main
pourquoi souffrir pourquoi lire tous les
penseurs pour pourquoi pendant toute
l'histoire de la pensée oui dans ce sens
là j'ai succombé à cette tentation et
c'est dans cet état d'esprit que je suis
parti pour la guerre mais maintenant
c'est et maintenant c'est tout à fait
terminé aujourd'hui c'est tout à fait
terminée vous n'adhérez plus en rien
idéologiquement ont commis non c'est
cette année ça serait un péroné ce n'est
pas nous c'est pas de maintenant ce que
quand j'ai vu lorsque j'étais à la
guerre la vie réelle et ce qu'attend la
population la population des territoires
que nous libérions avec l'espérance il
nous demandait et nous demander ce que
vraiment maintenant l'école fausseront
d'issue est ce que maintenant pour une
pour un retard de 20 minutes on va plus
nous envoyer en prison parce qu'on leur
avait diffusé par mu et des tracts de
propagande j'ai compris cela la
profondeur de ce qui s'était passé et
ensuite la prison les camps montrent
éclairée de façon incomparable
tout le temps que j'ai passé dans les
camps j'ai pas ce fait passer mon temps
m'entretenir avec les détenus pour
comprendre l'histoire de mon pays le
sens du système les relations avec
l'occident ce qui se passait à
l'occident assez rapidement je me suis
débarrassé et à jamais mais de notre
temps là la jeunesse non
subit plus le même temps parce que dans
l'évolution de tout phénomène
il y a un poids maximal ce que hegel
appelait le développement extérieur non
pas le développement intérieur le succès
extérieur le plus grand succès extérieur
du communisme porte sur les années 30
et ce succès ne se répètera plus jamais
maintenant la jeunesse non seulement
n'est pas entraîné mais elle a un
véritable dégoût pour les dogues mais
simplement des impératifs de vie
l'obligent à recevoir un diplôme
n'oblige à ce pharisaïsme une autre
question
we are montgermont une question qui
revient à des centaines d'exemplaires
oui monsieur c'est le jeune et john
viennent parler du marxisme et à ce
propos
beaucoup de téléspectateurs oppose sa
position à celle de lieu ni de peluches
dit récemment à la télévision
ayant lui aussi comme monsieur
soljenitsyne été victimes de la
répression en union soviétique s'est
pourtant déclaré toujours marxiste alors
qu'elle est là l'opinion de sur socgen
et jean
en ce qui concerne les convictions de
l'oriental de leonid pays
le schip logis ici en occident en
quelques déclarations privés et publics
a dit sincèrement ignore beaucoup de
choses dans l'est de l'histoire de notre
pays de l'histoire du régime de la
répression qu'il veut consacrer
maintenant son temps pour étudier toutes
ces choses
c'est un désir sincère et ardent chez
lui est un peu dommage à lui-même où il
a été poussé par d'autres de faire des
déclarations publiques un peu avant
qu'il ne puisse étudier tous ces
problèmes
plus précisément notre mieux
comment nous dans les années 30 nous
sommes trouvés sous la coupe bien
entendu par la suite des couches moins
moins large de la population
vous avez pu faire attention et pu
prêter attention j'ai pu remarquer que
klouche dans notre vie moderne
la terminologie n'est plus très sûr on a
eu des mots qui n'ont plus une
signification très précises plus jeudi
simultanément que c'est un communiste
convaincu qu'il est dévoué aux idéaux
lumineux du communisme et en même temps
il nie complètement le régime soviétique
tel qu'il existe en union soviétique
dans la mesure où j'ai compris depuis
son commencement
qu'est-ce que cela signifie ou bien ce
régime est communiste où il n'est pas
communiste
logique ce régime n'est pas communiste
alors à part à partir de quel moment il
n'est plus communiste
quelles sont les idées au lumineux qu'il
s'agit de reconstituer maintenant il est
démontré tout le monde sait que notre
régime a été du 25 octobre 1917 qui n'a
pas changé que tout l'archipel et que
tout tous les systèmes de répression ont
été créés par lénine plus encore ce
régime était condamnée à être ce qu'il
est depuis l'année 1903
depuis le moment du deuxième parti du
congrès du parti
quand a été créé un parti d'un nouveau
type un parti qui était soumis à une à
une volonté unique sans faille que
l'idéal eût minutes avant ce second
congrès du parti bolchévik marx mais
dans l'édition russe de marx engels
toutes les éditions occidentale après la
révision de caoutchouc qui ont masqué
cela dans l'édition russe de marx engels
dans leur correspondance
vous pouvez voir que la même cuisine est
la même
manière de diriger on la retrouve chez
mars
est-ce que poussée de quoi il parle et
tous ceux qui sont d'accord avec lui et
jusqu'à quand va-t-on marché vers les
idéaux lumineuse combien de siècles et
où les chercher oui notre question il
berkane oui un certain nombre de
téléspectateurs reproche à monsieur
soljenitsyne d'avoir choisi pour se
rendre au chili
la date de la veine ont plutôt du
deuxième anniversaire de l'avènement du
général pinochet au pouvoir du chili et
8 pose cette question
savait-il lorsqu'il est allé là-bas où
at il su sur place qu'il existait
également au chili des camps
d'internement à cette question en arcade
c'est ce qui se remarque à rattacher à
tous les points de vue de cette annonce
c'est une invention des journaux et
pourtant je sache c'est le monde qui a
publié cette invention peut-être n'est
pas le seul journal peut-être c'est une
agence de presse qui a diffusé cette
nouvelle
c'est un mensonge d'un bout à l'autre
non seulement je ne suis pas allé je ne
vais préparer pas je n'ai même pas reçu
d'invitation il en est pas été question
il n'y a eu qu'un seul coup une
invention journalistique c'est très
intéressant d'une part je ne sais pas
été publiés en bonne place et maintenant
toutes les têtes toutes les cervelle de
singe et demandé aux éditions du seuil
de dénoncer ce mensonge est la même le
même journal le monde a publié un
démenti mais de façon assez vous allez
en mauvaise place je suis contraint
maintenant je 2 à travers le vide à
travers les téléspectateurs de poser une
question en français à toute la presse
occidentale
quand j'ai été en union soviétique je
représentais les choses ainsi en
occident la presse est libre on ne peut
pas mentir on peut toujours donner un
démenti en union soviétique en effet la
presse est entièrement mensongère est ce
qu'on vous dit d'en haut mais quand je
viens dans votre presse dans votre
presse libre
on peut parfaitement mentir avec
beaucoup d'à dresse comme dans la presse
soviétique
le même journal le monde a réussi à
publier en gros caractères que mon
discours américain était un discours aux
pros hitlérien tous d'où ça peut venir
et voilà j'ai dit simplement en
adressant au monde libre occidental
quand vous êtes tous ensemble lüthi
contre hitler il fallait le vaincre de
ses propres mains et non pas demander un
ennemi pire encore de l'aide
un totalitarisme plus féroce encore qui
maintenant s'est établi pour plus d'un
demi siècle
autrement dit je propose est alors au
monde occidental de triompher d'hitler
sans l'aide de la russie soviétique et
on a dit de ce discours que c'est un
discours pro hitlérien en ce qui
concerne le chili je dois dire
j'attire l'attention j'entends le mot
chili beaucoup plus souvent que je
n'entends le le mur de berlin que par
exemple l'occupation dangréaux de la
tchécoslovaquie
comme par exemple de nos chambres à gaz
actuelle c'est-à-dire les prisons
psychiatrique
si le chili n'existait pas il aurait
fallu l'inventer
je n'ai jamais porter de jugement sur
des choses que je ne connais pas
suffisamment n'ait pas été au chili je
ne connais pas exactement la situation
nous jugeons les gouvernements des
autres d'après les manifestations
extérieures
il ya peu de temps et il s'est produit
une chose assez originale qui n'a pas
créé par retrouver dans la presse un
certain nombre d'émigrés chiliens qui
ont pu quitter le chili librement sont
arrivés en roumanie ils sont arrivés
dans ce paradis qu'ils avaient voulu
faire pour leur propre peuple et quand
ils sont trouvés dans ce paradis ils ont
été effrayés ils ont demandé qu'on les
relâche
mais la roumanie laissait pas partir
avec de grosses difficultés sont quand
même réussi à s'échapper en allemagne
occidentales qu'elles la presse on n'a
pratiquement pas parlé
un cas assez semblables les terroristes
du québec ont vécu entre au cube
là ils ont goûté du bonheur de castro
ils ont réussi avec difficulté à s'en
échapper
tous ainsi ils organisent pour leur
peuple
le paradis dans lequel ils ne voudront
pas vivre ensuite je me souviens ce cas
le chili a proposé à la russie
soviétique
nous allons tous les deux libérer nos
détenus politiques chacun les siens
l'union soviétique lui entendu n'a même
pas prêté l'oreille mais pourquoi
l'opinion publique occidentale n'a pas
profité de ce moment 1 pourquoi on n'a
pas essayé de mettre en pratique ce pari
que le chili et la russie soviétique
libèrent leurs propres de tenir le chili
libérer ceux qui se sont défendus ou qui
ont attaqué les armes à la main qu'ils
ont tirés tandis que la russie mythique
devait libérer ce simplement qu'ils
lisent l'évangile qui pensent autrement
nous n'avons pas chez nous des gens qui
qui ont été coffrés parce qu'il passe
qui l'ont fait les soulèvements parce
qu'ils ont pris là les armes qu'ils ont
créé des partis la russie soviétique n'a
pas libéré un seul détenu à ce moment là
le chili a commencé à libérer un certain
nombre de détenus sais pas combien
peut-être une partie peut être la moitié
des détenus peut-être les trois quarts
je me souviens castro fidel castro
le héros de l'agression d'aujourd'hui en
angola et bientôt il va nous montrer
d'autres va montrer d'autres choses en
afrique et en amérique du sud a été en
chimie en 71 71
là il a été triomphalement reçu pendant
longtemps et là il s'est exprimé non pas
comme un autre mais comme un maître
il a dit le socialisme ne peut être ne
peut être établie par des voies
pacifiques
il faut toujours les armes pour
installer le socialisme s'il n'a pas
réussi à le faire au chili maintenant il
le montre en angola
je me suis cachée de la question mais je
suis étonné pourquoi la presse
occidentale
je ne sais pas peut-être peut-être dans
la presse on donnera un exemple pourquoi
pas un seul journal pas un seul
correspondant de presse essayer d'écrire
un repentir de se repentir par exemple
nous notre journal nous avons donné
l'information
nous avons un fluide sur l'opinion
publique
c était une direction erronée nous
demandons à être pardonné devant nous
avons commis une erreur je me suis
trompé
comprenez pas tous ceux qui on eu tout
est mauvais toutes les annonces
mensongères comme ça disparaisse comme
s'ils n'ont jamais existé mais
honnêtement il faut quand même
reconnaître même les erreurs théorique
notre question oui c'est de l'art manger
mou nous coûter le spectateur interroge
alexandre seul gène et d'une à propos de
ses déclarations les déclarations qu'il
a faites au cours de sa tournée
américaine à propos de la détente que
seuls les unes dénoncent comme un danger
pour le monde occidental
deux types de la question pourquoi cette
opposition à la détente
et ne pensez vous pas que la détente par
une meilleure circulation en créant
précisément une meilleure circulation
des hommes et des idées est une
meilleure chance de liberté propre aux
anciens compagnons du goût
je dois dire que depuis beaucoup de
choses ont changé je suis intervenu aux
états unis mais maintenant l'initiateur
américain de la détente refusent
maintenant ce mot même cette politique
est en train de changer mes objections
est très simple tout à fait simple je
dis simplement dans leur siècle
il faut définir les mots qu'est ce que
c'est la détente la détente pour
l'occident qu'on pense que c'est c'est
faire des choses agréables pour la
partie adverse cd ne pas insister ça on
peut le comprendre
seulement on ne peut pas comprendre si
vous occident libre pourquoi vous
considérez que vos limites sont les
limites aux frontières sont les
frontières de la liberté pourquoi vous
considérez que vous pouvez vous que vous
pouvez garder la liberté pour vous alors
que chez nous elle puisse ne pas exister
mais mes objections temps d en fait de
la part de l'union soviétique
il n'y a pas eu un seul jour de détente
pas un seul jour en fait l'union
soviétique continue la même guerre
froide qu'il a toujours mené mais mais
maintenant elle s'appelle rivalités
idéologiques compétition idéologique
cela signifie que que dans les
profondeurs du pays tant des milliers de
conférences de sessions d'étude
on cherche à introduire dans les crânes
que vous êtes des impérialistes que vous
êtes des capitalistes que vous sucer le
sang des colonies et que vous voulez
continuer de faire la même chose
cela donne la possibilité à l'union
soviétique en quelques heures de
modifier la situation politique en
quelques il suffit d'appuyer sur un
bouton et les journaux pas répond
correspondant à cette propagande qui est
menée en profondeur
moi je dis c'est que je ne comprenais
pas ce que c'est la détente
mais moi je comprends ce que c'est
qu'une pomme vient déclarer sur cette
pomme il n'y a pas de mains il n'y a pas
de pierre ouvrir la sainte baume et à ce
moment là il y aura des temps d'ouvrir
cette forme et pour cela il faut il faut
contrôler la renommant il n'y a toujours
pas de contrôle c'est toujours il faut
cesser cesser cette lutte idéologique
non seulement elle s'affaiblit belle se
renforce en union soviétique
comme vous êtes vous vous êtes en train
de par vos concessions de conte de
conforter l'union soviétique
voilà quelques exemples il ya deux ans
on a eu peur de moi et on est expulsé et
aujourd'hui sakharov
on habite
on a même vous n'avez même pas pu
réussir aph à ce que sa parole soit
envoyé assister à la réception du prix
nobel
aujourd'hui correspondant vos
correspondants moscou ont reçu un peu
plus de liberté un tout petit peu plus
et agissant dans l'esprit de la détente
ils ne prennent pas il essaie de ne pas
faire passer des informations
désagréable afin de pas gêner la détente
et voilà on frappe à la porte de nicolas
cru qu on ait vu vérifier le gaz
il les laisse entrer et là il veut et le
rouent de coups
si tu va encore continuer à faire des
déclarations voilà ce qui arrivera
on continue d'arrêter dans l'épreuve
dans les provinces métier cela figurent
ou non fait d'autres à moscou dans la
rue deux jours encore les gens
maîtrisent et personne ne proteste
personne n'ose même levé les yeux c'est
ça la détente chez nous merci comme
résultat de cette détente la puissance
de l'union soviétique s'est renforcée
par rapport à vous que maintenant les
boulons sont si les villes sont serrés
ces derniers temps vous n'entendez
pratiquement rien de ce qui se passe en
russie soviétique sur les nouvelles
répressions qui ont lieu là bas ça c'est
la détente
tout le monde a peur de vous faire
parvenir l'information
comme si de rien n'était pour reprendre
la question que vient de poser jamais
laquelle vous avez répondu dans le même
discours américain ou dans un autre
on ne sait pas exactement enfin dans un
des disques ou aux américains que vous
avez fait devant le syndicat afl cio
vous dites seule la fermeté permet de
résister aux assauts du totalitarisme
soviétique et vous donner un certain
nombre d'exemples
autrement dit vous pensez que la détente
est nocif pour les occidentaux
c'est ce que vous venez d'expliquer et
que seule la la fermeté doit payer
je voudrais rappeler que j'interviens
non pas comme un homme politique
et quand je parle de fermeté j'ai vu non
seulement n'ont pas tellement la fermeté
de vos armes et de vos notes
diplomatiques mais de la fermeté de
votre esprit processus il a commencé
depuis bien longtemps
il a commencé bien avant cette détente
il a commencé avant munich il a commencé
à partir de 1918 et si on y réfléchit
bien il dure depuis des siècles c'est un
processus
quand les gens qui se trouvent dans le
confort ne veulent pas entendre parler
des souffrances d'autrui
voilà vous avez fini la première guerre
mondiale qu'est ce qui se passait chez
nous notre pays et est votre allié
comment vous nous avez laissé à
l'esclavagé mais vous vouliez avant tout
goûter un peu de repos pour reposer la
preuve cette terrible première guerre
mondiale qu'est ce qui s'est passé après
la seconde guerre mondiale
mais entre les deux il ya eu munich sud
et moi c'était la même chose surtout
repoussé l'échéance cd continuer de
céder et vraiment on a fait des
concessions mais c'était beaucoup trop
proche
il a fallu faire la guerre l'occident
adopté une position systématique et
cette épreuve il a traversé
courageusement mais après de nouveau il
avoue l'occident voulu se reposer a
voulu du repos et là vous avez de
nouveau renvoyé à l' esclavage
mais c'est avec les crosses les cross
occidentales frappées les vieillards et
les enfants pour livrer les gens à
l'archipel du goulag
c'est ainsi que 1 million et demi de
soviétiques ont été renvoyés dans les
forêts la masse les foules ne le savait
pas mais les gens éclairés nevo
communiste qui venait souvent chez nous
connaissaient très bien notre esclavage
tous faisait silence et la société était
contente
comme il est bon de et d'ignorer les
souffrances d'autrui de continuer à
vivre dans le confort quand je parle la
fermeté je prends la fermeté dan lorsque
nous les dissidents est ce que nous
avons des temps qu'est ce que nous avons
des avions est ce que nous avons la
possibilité d'envoyer des notes
diplomatiques
notre résistance reposer entièrement sur
la fermeté de la uniquement notre patrie
nous n'avions que voilà notre poitrine
nous avions à fermeté de notre volonté
si vous avez la liberté cette liberté il
faudra il faudra la défense penser
chaque année on ne cesse de perdre cette
liberté plusieurs pays
percevez vous êtes comme dans un sorte
de l'oubli c'est un processus qui dure
depuis longtemps
c'est un processus qui dure depuis
plusieurs siècles
il a commencé sans doute ont décidé
qu'au dessus de il n'y avait personne
qu'il n'y avait pas de l'exigence
supérieur uniquement une philosophie
pragmatique des calculs d'affaires
philosophie pragmatique et ses calculs
sans obligation éthique sans obligation
morale amené l'occident à cet état
chacun veut jouir de la liberté mais ne
veut pas répondre et défendre cette
raison de cet hiver et la défense mais
l'homme se distinguent l'animal en ceci
un sens qui s'est non seulement ne pas
jouer s'il s'est non seulement jouir
mais également avoir un devoir et savoir
se limiter se limiter dans ses désirs
dit l'avoir
oui d'abord
je vais passer la parole à marcel
jullian mais je dois informer aussi bien
vous même monsieur soljenitsyne et les
téléspectateurs qui nous regardent que
nous avons l'autorisation d'aller
jusqu'à 23h45 il et 32 non je reste
exactement douze minutes de monsieur oui
et comme on approche de la fin il ya des
mêmes une série de questions qui
reviennent au quotidien et qui merci et
qui font état de la possibilité
éventuelle une évolution du régime
communiste à l'intérieur de l'urss
qu'elle est à ce sujet le pronostic fait
par monsieur soljenitsyne poète comment
voit-il la russie dans 10 ou 20 ans et
pense t-il en vain compte qu'ils iront
droit un jour quand j'ai été expulsé
j'ai été encore saisie thion charles
mesure c'est par ce sentiment de fermeté
que mes amis que mes compatriotes honte
éprouvée dans cette ascension
progressive de cet esclavage qui fut
notre de cette absence de droit pour que
précisément avec nos poitrines nues
le pi sion nous défendre contre l'as
wihr la violence
j'ai été encore saisie j'étais encore
tôt pénétré de cet optimisme et c'est
pour cela je peux je pensais qu'il est
parfaitement réel on peut parler avant
les perspectives du développement d'une
évolution de notre régime je n'étais pas
le seul à penser ainsi
mais les deux années que j'ai passées
ici en occident j'ai vu tant que l'état
de volonté délabré se trouve l'occident
ou là bas chez nous pour un naïvement
que l'occident va nous sauver va nous
tirer du malheur
je ne vais jamais cru et je ne croyais
pas que nous étions en droit moralement
de l'attendre l'occident je considérais
toujours que nous devions nous libérer
nous même nom par deux révolutions non
par le sang mais nous avons perdu déjà
uniquement par les guerres civiles
depuis 1917 et jusqu'en 59 à travers les
répressions
nous avons perdu 66 millions d'âmes
c'est statistiquement scientifiquement
publié en occident et j'espère que la
presse occidentale ne reprendra la
presse française le reprendra je croyais
dans cette délivrance je pensais que par
un effort spirituel nous allions obligé
le régime a cédé mais quand je suis
arrivée en occident
et quand j'ai vu l'apathie générale
cette façon de ne pas croire à la menace
que les gens ne voulaient pas penser à
la liberté des autres
ces deux dernières années la situation
mondiale s'est notablement dégradé et
aujourd'hui je considère comme nom
actuel la question d'une évolution
favorable du régime soviétique je
considère cette question n'est pas
actuelle ces derniers années tout tout
tout est donnée pour une évolution non
favorable du régime soviétique qui sera
non favorable aux citoyens au sujet de
ce régime et qui ne sera pas favorable à
l'occident non plus je pense qu'il faut
poser ces questions n'ont pas moi mais
aux hommes d'occident quelles sont les
perspectives d'évolution de l'accident
cette question là elle serait actuelle
vous n'envisagez à aucun moment de dans
les moments de d'optimisme si je puis
dire entre guillemets vous n'envisagez
jamais de retourner dans votre pays dès
que cette possibilité ne sera offert si
on entendu je reviendrai partout j'ai
combien de temps je ne vivrai ici je me
sentirais comme un captif j'ai dit
depuis longtemps mon retour dans ma
patrie ce sont les livres d'aidés que
mes livres pourront être publiés en
russie
quand cet archipel sera pourra être lu
mais les russes n'ont pas lu encore à
part quelques heures quelques rares
livres qui ont pu pénétrer là-bas par
des voies détournées à partir de ce
moment là je considère que je suis comme
retourner
guy est bien alain jérôme si la caméra
nous regarde
voici en fait ces fiches qui représente
un cac est beaucoup plus important que
la moyenne des fiches que nous recevons
d'habitude c'est en fait l'image des
téléspectateurs qui nous ont regardé ce
soir qui se sont adressées directement
alexandre soljenitsyne et je crois que
c'est la concrétisation de
ce contact que nous avons cherché à
établir entre soljenitsyne et notre
public n'est ce pas oui cette émission
va se terminer là maintenant je voudrais
personnellement son antenne 2 pour mes
amis répondre à une remarque de
l'ensemble des téléspectateurs dont
beaucoup nous reproche d'avoir voulu
délibérément faire une émission
anticommuniste il n'y a aucune volonté
de fermer aucune émission à l'égard à
l'encontre de telles ou telles opinions
du public en france ce gentinetta donne
une dimension internationale
son témoignage est connu dans tous les
pays libres pourquoi ne recule pas pris
la parole à la télévision française
qu'il a donné son témoignage aux
français maintenant je pense de la
passion et d'en tirer des conclusions il
va dans un sens qui leur convient mais
non je pense que une des choses qui est
un peu étonné également c'est que
d'habitude ya débat nous a dit qu'il n'y
avait pas des bas cette fois ci nous
avons pensé à la convention précisément
de céline le nombre de questions qui
étaient posées la fois précédente et qui
avait été qui avait valu le courrier
après apostrophe justifier qu'il faut et
fut possible de poser toutes ces
questions quant aux raisons idéologiques
qui devinrent est un doute ils viennent
un exilé la fameuse phrase l'exil est
impie everett ou qu'elle nous
conviennent nous avions la même
générosité la même curiosité
si c'était nécessaire ouais le même
courage est-ce que je peux parler encore
aujourd'hui regardant directement
l'objectif j'ai éprouvé ce contact avec
les millions de téléspectateurs de ce
pays qui m'a tellement plu j'ai beaucoup
aimé ce pays j'ai pas mal parcouru la
france elle elle va le droit encore
c'est pas du tout un compliment moi je
ce n'est pas mon habitude de dire de
faire des compliments je regrette que
des spectateurs vous ont écrit en
parlant de ce dialogue comme d'un
concert anticommuniste si on peut après
le film qu'on a vu un dialogue sur nos
souffrances l'appeler un concert ça veut
dire que les hommes qui ont posé ces
questions
ils n'ont pas de coeur ils ne peuvent
comprendre les souffrances parce qu'ils
n'ont pas éprouvé le mot de concerts est
insultant nos souffrances ne sont pas
anti communiste ce sont des souffrances
nous mêmes mais le communisme est anti
humain il faut cesser d'utiliser ces
mots qui sont pas naturels
anticommunisme nous sommes des hommes
nous voulions vivre comme des hommes
on nous a imposé un régime anti humain
on l'a appelée communiste allons
terminer cette émission monsieur jean
est ce qu'il y à une question que le
public ne vous a pas posé ou qu'on n'a
pas eu le temps de vous poser à laquelle
vous auriez aimé répondre je comprends
qu'on peut parler beaucoup et posez
encore d'innombrables questions
je voudrais comprendre bien comprendre
j'ai fait plusieurs interventions ces
dernières un ces derniers temps ceux qui
m'ont interviewé et en l'occurrence
certains téléspectateurs cherche à me
faire répondre sur des questions
politiques
nous devons nous nous donnons pas nous
limiter aux plans politique si le plan
politique le plan politique est un plan
misérable pauvres il y a de la droite de
la gauche mais elle n'a pas de
profondeur ni d'élévation de hauteur
jamais aucun parti aucune n'a donné de
grandes décisions de grandes solutions
humaines la crise du monde actuel est
beaucoup plus complexe et aujourd'hui
avec vous en tant qu'écrivain je dois
dire honnêtement j'ai ajouté des
questions plus plus profond dans leur
sans signification
mais j'ai entendu j'entends parler de
concerts anticommuniste 6-2-2
d'élections cantonales ou municipales
je comprends que ces questions sont bien
arrivés je pense que ces questions
profondes sont arrivés mais que n'ont
pas réussi à percer à travers la masse
des questions plus superficielle je
voudrais comprendre
sincèrement parce que nous parlons de
souffrance et qu'il s'agit de politique
c'est pas de notre faute nous voulions
simplement vivre mais notre vie a été
tordu et on a fait de la politique
voilà d'où vient la politique j'aurais
préféré parler de problèmes spirituels
mais j'ai déjà essayé de gym
la situation actuelle ce n'est pas sain
de l'occident s'est pas seulement une
crise politique
c'est une crise spirituelle triste qui a
peut-être trois siècles d'existence
cette crise vient de ce que dans le haut
moyen âge nous sommes j'étais vers la
matière nous avons voulu avoir beaucoup
d'objets voulions vivre pour tout ce qui
est chara elle sait que les tâches
éthique des tâches moral nous avons
oublié et c'est par un coup de retour
tardif que nous on subit ce que nous
subissons bien alexandre soljenitsyne je
vous remercie d'avoir bien voulu
répondre à toutes les questions que vous
ont été posées je remercie également
tous ceux qui nous ont prêté attention
jusqu'à maintenant et nous allons clore
nous allons terminer cette émission
avant de vous souhaiter une bonne fin de
soirée de vous proposer un nouveau
rendez vous avec les dossiers de l'écran
mardi prochain bonsoir
[Musique]